if we look back on what consciousness
previously took and now takes
responsibility for on what it previously
ascribed and now ascribes to the thing
we see that consciousness alternately
makes itself as well as the thing into
both a pure many less one and into an
all so that resolves itself into
independent matters consciousness thus
finds through this comparison that not
only it's truthful perceiving contains
the distinct moments of apprehension and
withdrawal into itself but rather that
the truth itself the thing reveals
itself in this twofold way our
experience that is this that the thing
exhibits itself for the consciousness
apprehending it in a specific manner but
is at the same time reflected out of the
way in which it presents itself to
consciousness and back into itself in
other words it contains in its own self
an opposite truth to that which it has
for the apprehending consciousness
having spent a considerable amount of
time and ink in developing this
dialectic that's occurring between
consciousness and the object of
consciousness occurring in perception or
VAR naman the literally taking the truth
of the the object for consciousness
we're now at about the midpoint and what
we're going to see happening in the next
several paragraphs is that there's going
to be a doubling that's been there
implicit the entire time but now being
made explicit by the phenomenological
analysis so Hegel is going to say that
there's something going on in
consciousness and another consciousness
is taking in both consciousness another
thing and as we're gonna see other
things and you know even what's beyond
consciousness but consciousness has been
approaching the thing in perception as
if the thing has its particular
composition or characteristics or
qualities and truth lies entirely on the
side of the thing very much as it is
with sense certainty and it's finding
out that no truth ends up being you
might say diffused into the relationship
between these and what we're gonna see
happen is that consciousness which is up
until this point then saying well if
there's any there's anything in here
that doesn't coincide with this
that's falsity and that lies on the side
of consciousness it's going to find
something similar occurring even in the
object itself and thereby you might say
validating itself as what's been
previously been made responsible or even
guilty for the illusions or
misperceptions that are going on so
Hegel is going to say that if we look
back at what consciousness previously
took responsibility for we see
consciousness all truly alternately
makes itself as well as the thing it's
it's realizing that there's a similarity
of structure there into both a pure many
less one something that's lacking
multiplicity precisely because it has
unity you might say that's the cost of
having unity in a sense where the unity
is meaningful where the unity asserts
itself the unity makes the portions the
parts the components into the things
that don't really matter as much because
the focus is on the one by the way I put
the also which is in your text in
capital letters choice on Miller the
translators part into a lowercase to
stress that with the also with the
multiplicity with the the medium as
we've seen for stressing this aspect of
it the thing becomes just a bearer of
qualities or predicates sore however you
want to talk about it and those exist in
concrete determinate relations to each
other pushing off each other as I've
said before relating relating to each
other by way of opposition being what
they are precisely by not being the
other and that's made possible for those
properties because the thing in that
respect doesn't assert itself as a unity
but just something that kind of you know
glues them together the medium in which
they can occur and we've got a doubling
of aspect here both of these are indeed
what it is that the one and
consciousness are so if you're going to
ask yourself well what is the thing
there's no simple answer to it at this
point and that's actually a great
realization because up until now Hegel
has had consciousness trying out this
simple answer and this simple answer it
always turns out that every simple
answer is more complicated than we
thought but that shouldn't be a surprise
at this point and going through Hegel
shouldn't so he says consciousness thus
finds for this comparison that not only
it's truthful perceiving where it is
perceiving the thing and sort of taking
in the thing he might say into itself
contains the distinct moments of
apprehension and withdrawal into itself
you know these these two sides but
rather that the truth itself the thing
reveals itself in this twofold way so
there's a similarity of you might say
structure of relationship going on
between consciousness consciousness of
the thing and what's actually there in
the thing itself there's a very
important realization so he says our
experience then is this the thing
exhibits itself for the consciousness
apprehending it in a specific manner but
it is at the same time reflected out of
the way in which it presents itself to
consciousness and back into itself that
is this this movement of you know unity
the reflection back into itself that's
what gives it this oneness this you
might even say substantiality and the
same thing by the way is going on or
consciousness consciousness asserts
itself as having presence as really
being there this is what gives these
things the capacity to be able to
reflect upon themselves now what does
that mean doesn't mean that the thing is
conscious Hegel is not going quite so
far but there is some dynamic relation
to self that is going on that is not
encompassed by consciousness but can be
noted by consciousness within the very
being of the thing that's something
worth mulling over so it's not just the
unity of the thing that's being
reflected into itself it's also the
contrast between the unity and the
multiplicity that is being reflected
into itself but that becomes the less
important sign at least at this point he
says in other words it contains in its
own self an opposite truth to that which
it has for the apprehending
consciousness the things now you might
say asserting itself against what the
perceiving
this wants to take yeah and again
consciousness is able to note this but
it's not able to entirely assimilate it
these sort of things over here you might
say they can indeed be assimilated you
know we think it again about the the
organs the multiplicity within
consciousness the you know the taste the
smell the the the feeling the sight and
all that that can be taken in this can
only be grasped in a somewhat different
way or approached in a different way as
I said noted it can be realized it can
be experienced but not completely
brought with into the purview of
consciousness and we're going to see in
the following paragraphs
thus consciousness has got beyond this
second type of attitude and perceiving
to that is the one in which it takes the
thing is truly self identical and its
self for what is not self identical but
returns back into itself out of identity
the object is now for consciousness this
whole movement which was previously
shared between the object and
consciousness the thing is a one
reflected into itself it is for itself
but it is also for and other and
moreover it is an other on its own
account just because it is for another
accordingly the thing is for itself and
also for another a being that is doubly
differentiated but also a one but the
oneness contradicts this diversity hence
consciousness would again have to assume
responsibility for placing the diversity
and the one and for keeping it away from
the thing it would have to say that
insofar as it is for itself the thing is
not for an other but the oneness also
belongs to the thing itself as
consciousness is found by experience the
thing is essentially reflected into
itself the also or the indifferent
difference
thus falls as much within the thing as
does the oneness but since the two are
different they do not fall within the
same thing but in different things the
contradiction which is present in the
objective essence as a whole is
distributed between two objects in and
for itself the thing is self identical
but this unity with itself is disturbed
by other things
thus the unity of the thing is preserved
and at the same time the other necessar
side the thing as well as outside of
consciousness
in Section 123 consciousness is still
part of the picture it's still engaging
in perception we have it still observing
what's going on in perception but most
of the development that's going to take
place in this paragraph is going to
happen on the side of the thing so
consciousness is looking on and seeing
what's going on in its perception
there's a number of different things
happening here that can get mixed up so
we want to try to disentangle them we
want to sit we don't want to say they're
totally separate from each other because
Hegel doesn't think that they're
actually separate but they are
distinguishable so he says we've gotten
beyond the second kind of attitude and
perceiving the one which took the thing
is really self identical now we realize
that the thing itself is not self
identical and it's so not self identical
that it's turned into a duplicity a
duplicity of the one and the also or
differentiated multiplicity now it's
it's also reflected into itself it has
this relationship of being for itself
that in many respects we might think
only goes for conscious things but Hegel
says that things that are being
perceived are also for themselves in
this way metaphysically so he goes on
and he says it returns to itself back
into itself out of identity the object
is now for consciousness this whole
movement which was previously shared
between object and consciousness so the
thing is in our perception all these
dialectical developments that have been
taking place up until this point the
perceiving of it is at least implicitly
perceiving that this is in fact what is
wrapped up in perceiving a thing so he
says the thing is a1 it's reflected into
itself it's for itself right it has a
relation to itself as being a one that's
part of what the reflection is but it's
also for another you know we won't ask
what what is this other well we'll get
to that in just a moment
so he says it's for another moreover it
is an other on its own the count so this
thing itself is also an other two
whatever this other is here so it's an
other to this other that means that it
doesn't have it's being totally in in
itself you might say that that for Hegel
no object is simply what it is in an
inert way you know completely opaque or
passive where consciousness just has to
encounter it there's already a dynamism
going on both within the object and in
its relation to this other now we want
to figure out what what is that that
other so let's look at what he says
thing is a one reflected to itself as
for itself before another the thing is
for itself and also for another a being
that is doubly differentiated but also
one now what is that well that couldn't
be consciousness over here right so
maybe the for another is being for
consciousness but what we're actually
going to see going on in this entire
development is that the other is really
an other thing a being that like the
thing has unity yeah but also
differentiated multiplicity
so the thing is another for another
thing and this is a a relationship that
is reciprocal the the other thing takes
the thing as being its other and it goes
back and forth and back and forth we can
also say this other thing is also
related to itself and also does the
relationship or itself just like the
thing does now that's going to assume
more importance as we move into the next
paragraph here Hegel is not going to
develop that quite so much he's going to
focus on what's going on within the
thing itself
so he says consciousness or here we go
accordingly the thing is for itself and
also for another being that's double
doubly differentiated but also a one but
the oneness contradicts this diversity
there's still this tension going on here
and we also have a tension going on
between these because the oneness and
this and the oneness of myths are the
same kind of oneness so if this is what
makes the thing one it is what gives it
its substantiality well that's also over
here in this one so maybe it's not
entirely belonging to this one and the
one over here can say the same thing
because from its point of view with soul
as far as we can talk about having a
point of view this is the alien this is
the other this is the one that is a
reflection of itself so we going on he
says this oneness contradicts this
diversity hence consciousness would
again have to assume responsibility for
placing the diversity in the water and
keeping it away from the thing it would
have to say that insofar as it is for
itself
the thing is not for another but the
oneness belongs to the thing as
consciousness is found from experience
so consciousness is not going to fall in
the trap of saying oh I must have
screwed up over here the mistake is in
me you know these things that I'm
perceiving now because remember
perception is also of this thing
they're simple they exist in themselves
there's no you know complex dynam is
going on here there's no internal
contradiction to these things
consciousness can't see that anymore
because consciousness realizes that this
is the truth of the thing this is the
truth of perception that what we're
perceiving is something that is doubled
in its very essence in its very reality
America everything that we're perceiving
that's a thing has that characteristic
so he says what does consciousness
realized it had it it would have to save
him so far it is for itself it's not an
other
but the oneness belongs to the thing
itself is consciousness as found by
experience that thing is essentially
reflected into itself to be a one
consciousness has realized means that
you can't be entirely a one that you
have to have this dynamic tension
between the two of these and I'm there
has to be this relationship of being
being related to itself in other nests
well they're also to another in all
their nests right so he goes on and he
says you would have to say that insofar
as it is for it's all the thing is not
for another but we know that that's not
the case so the also or the indifferent
difference the difference that doesn't
make a difference the literally go
either way like goo tiga winter she thus
falls as much within the thing as does
the oneness but since the two are
different they don't fall within the
same thing but in different things this
is sort of cast out the getting
different difference casts down to the
thing and becomes its own thing so the
thing already contains a multiplicity of
famous within itself because it seems
like it wants to do this but it's also
this at the same time it can't hold
itself together ontologically and yet it
still does to some degree
so he says the contradiction which is
present in the objective essence as a
whole is distributed between two objects
what are these two objects this and this
the unity and the multiplicity but it's
also being distributed between the thing
in another whole thing on which we can
say the same thing that we haven't also
here so we have in many respects not
just a dyadic relation but a quadratic
relation where the same is the same
process animal said the same thing the
same process is occurring within the
thing as this is occurring in the other
thing this bifurcation this splitting
this tension this contradiction within
them so he says in for itself the thing
is self identical but that doesn't get
us anywhere so the innum for itself is
not really what the thing is this unity
within itself is disturbed by what other
things other presences other dynamic
sets of relations within themselves the
unity of the thing is preserved and at
the same time the other nests is
preserved outside of the thing as well
as outside of consciousness now that
gets really interesting that's something
to reflect on consciousness has been
observing this the whole time right so
there's something that's outside of both
the thing or the other thing and outside
of consciousness now it's not going to
remain outside of consciousness because
this is an idealism right we want to
bring it back into consciousness but it
presents a challenge that paragraphs you
know 124 and on are gonna have to
respond to so you notice we've got a
very messy chalkboard here why do we
have such a messy chalkboard because
there's so much going on within a single
thing a single thing like a piece of
chalk turns out to be so much more
complex than we ever thought to begin
with
now although it is true that the
contradiction in the objective essence
is in this way distributed among
different things yet the difference will
for that reason attach to the singular
separated thing itself the different
things are thus established as existing
on their own account and the conflict
between them is so far reciprocal that
each is different not from itself but
only from the other but each is thereby
determined as being itself a different
thing and has its essential difference
in its own self
all the while not as if this difference
were an opposition in the thing itself
on the contrary for itself it is simple
it is a simple determinate mnestheus
enchi yet sit from others as a matter of
fact since different Ness is present in
it it is of course necessarily present
as an actual difference manifold Li
constituted but because the determinant
ness constitutes the essence of the
thing by which it distinguishes itself
from other things and is for itself this
further manifold Constitution is the
unofficial aspect consequently the thing
does indeed have the twofold insofar
within its unity but the aspects are
unequal in value as a result this state
of opposition does not develop into an
actual opposition and the thing itself
but insofar as a thing through its
absolute difference comes into a state
of opposition it is opposed to another
thing outside of it of course the
further manifold this is necessarily
present in the thing too so then it
cannot be left out but it is the
essential aspect of the thing
now in section 124 we're going to see a
little bit of a progression or you might
say a leaving behind occur and we've got
the thing over here it's rather complex
but we're actually going to say some of
this is less important some of it is
unattentive invasive leakin in Hegel's
terminology and if we wanted to bring in
terms that he's not using in this
paragraph which are very helpful you'd
say that in thinking about the one on
the also they also becomes less
important at this point we've spent a
lot of time sketching it out the
necessity for the thing to be both a 1
and unity and also and as well and also
a manifold of differences preserved
together in a kind of you know neutral
medium in which the differences
themselves can push against each other
can oppose to each other that that's
what qualities er properties can do and
we're gonna we're going to de-emphasize
that now in this part because we've seen
that the thing exists by way of
opposition to other things so we have at
the first thing at the first part of the
paragraph it's hard to avoid all this
also in thin language isn't it we ought
to really be careful when we're doing
this so we have a thing in an exists
indifference to a thing and notice I've
got other in parentheses here because
either one of these could be seen as the
other for this thing this thing is
nothing but it's also another to the
other thing it views the thing over here
as its other but this thing over here
views that one has its other and so far
as that's the case these are actually in
a difference which is a difference of a
sort of identity isn't it in any case he
says it's true that the contradiction
and the objective essence is distributed
among different things what is he
referring to we've just talked about the
difference between the one and the all
so and they also almost almost gets cast
out of the thing turning into itself
another kind of thing we might better
say that there is two ways of looking at
the thing and these don't always match
up to each other you can't get them to
coincide and remain in harmony he says
the difference will for that reason
attach to the singular separated thing
itself the different things are thus
established as each existing on its own
account each of them is a you might say
contradiction within itself that manages
to perder nonetheless and oppose itself
to our consciousness and to every other
thing it is abundant with or is related
to so he says the conflict between them
is reciprocal in in this way each is
different not from itself but from the
other this is different from this this
is different from this they're also
different from themselves insofar as
they have you also but now we're
focusing on this if we look at it in
this way each of these things is what he
calls a simple determinate Ness
they having being determined being in a
certain way and it's simple because it's
a one it's a unity it's opposed to
another simple determinant is
each of them is in itself each of them
hands and in itself or exists as in in
itself so he goes on and he says the
different things are established as
existing on their own account each is
determined as being itself a different
thing it has its essential difference in
its own self but all the while not as if
this difference we're in opposition in
the thing itself why not an opposition
and the thing itself we know that
there's an opposite
the thing itself don't we well because
another opposition comes to the fore as
being more important as drawing our
attention as telling us hey perceiving
is not just perceiving this thing in its
qualities and you know hat going through
that well is it a unity is it and also
but perceiving this as opposed to as
different from in contrast you might say
from this so we not only have difference
going on insofar as these are in itself
we also have differentiation between
these simple determinate nests
we have difference and differentiation
difference is something you might say we
could say that is rather just passive
for consciousness differentiation is
where these things say we are not the
same we are different from we are not
equal to each other
you cannot substitute one of us for the
other even though in many respects you
probably can't can't you you know two
forks in a drawer or something along
those lines so he goes omni says as a
matter of fact since different nests is
present in it it's of course necessarily
present as an actual difference manifest
manifold lis constitute but because that
determinist constitutes the essence of
the thing by which it it distinguishes
itself from other things and it is for
itself that's what it means to be it is
for itself at this time to being for
self it's at this level that the
difference matters this now becomes uh
nacelle it's not going to vanish
entirely it's going to assume some
importance but at this point in the
dialectic this is not where the truth of
the thing of perception of the object
lies yet so he says the thing Duns you
have this this twofold insofar within
its unity these aspects are unequal and
value so the state of opposition does
not develop into an actual opposition of
the
itself so we we don't actually have like
we saw in the previous paragraph a
separate thing yes he also he also is
just sort of dragged back in you might
think of it as as being sucked in by the
gravitational force of the unity the the
greater force the greater strength the
also doesn't resist it as well and and
just goes along for the ride so he says
the state of opposition does not develop
into an actual opposition of the thing
itself but insofar as a thing through
its absolute difference comes into a
state of opposition it's opposed to
another thing outside of it it's not
opposed just within itself it's now
being opposed to something that is a
different entity something that opposes
it something that it resists it
something that says I am NOT you so he
says of course the further manifold this
is necessarily present in the thing too
so that it cannot be left out but it is
the UH essential aspect of the thing
both of this thing and of this thing
they both have and also that's as I just
said a moment ago being dragged along
for the ride but which is not going to
matter insofar as we're opposing things
to each other at least not at this point
you